Our drug policy has really been
traditionally based on racism and
moralizing.
The reason that they currently illegal
drugs are illegal,
has nothing to do with the scientific
evaluation of the relative risks and
benefits.
Otherwise,
you could never come up with a situation
where marijuana is illegal and tobacco
is legal.
You cannot make a rational argument for
that.
That comes from racism.
Um,
and the,
and colonialism,
the drug laws were made in explicitly
racist circumstances for explicitly
racist reasons.
For example,
the first anti cocaine laws were made
because cocaine supposedly made black
men impervious to bullets and prone to
getting involved with white women.
This is complete nonsense where there is
no science to it whatsoever.
And yet it was published in the New York
Times in the early 19 hundreds.
So this is where our laws come from and
we have to be honest about that and we
have to stop pretending that there is
some kind of rational basis for the laws
that we currently have.
Then what we need to do is realize that
you can't make policy based on,
I think it's bad for you to have honor
and pleasure.
You have to make policy based on does
this hurt you,
does this hurt other people?
And the,
that's where harm reduction comes from.
The basic idea of harm reduction is what
policy will most reduce the harm related
to drugs.
And once you start to focus on harm,
you have to look not only at harm
associated with drugs,
but harm associated with drug policy.
And this is why so many harm reduction
people rapidly become legalizers because
the harm associated with drug
prohibition has not produced the results
that people would like.
It does not stop addiction.
It does not,
um,
you know,
prevent kids from using drugs.
It makes the kids who use drugs be at
higher risk of dying from them on.
It doesn't,
you know,
Saves Society's productivity by like
keeping people from taking substances
that will make them not work on.
It just doesn't work.
And when you think about it,
if addiction is defined as compulsive
behavior despite negative consequences
and you're trying to use negative
consequences in order to stop it,
something is seriously wrong there.
So our drug policy has to acknowledge
the reality that punishment doesn't fix
addiction.
And that putting drug users in cages
does nothing but worse than the problem
and it doesn't deter kids.
Um,
at least idea that like,
oh,
if we just really stigmatize this and
make everybody hate drug users,
then kids will never use drugs.
Kids are going to do stupid,
risky things.
You want to reduce the chances that
those things will kill them.
The idea that can prevent adolescents
from having sex or prevent adolescents
from doing some kind of risky behavior
is just absurd.
This,
you know,
comes out before humans even evolved.
Again,
this is where it comes back to racism.
Our image of the typical drug user or
the typical drug addict is basically the
same as our racist stereotype of
whichever groups we happen to be
targeting.
So criminal,
lying,
manipulative,
deceitful,
Ahm,
you know,
all of these things that we project onto
other people and then stigmatize and
attack them for,
um,
we do the same with drug users.
Obviously if you make a behavior that
someone feels is essential to their
survival,
illegal,
they are going to lie to protect that
behavior.
That doesn't mean that they're
fundamentally a dishonest person.
The reason that we continue to have
these stereotypes about who drug users
are is because of the ongoing racism of
our society.
And until we acknowledge that like I am
the typical drug user,
if there is such a thing,
um,
you know,
I don't look like your stereotype,
but that doesn't mean that the
stereotype is accurate.
Um,
so I think that's a really important
thing that people really have to learn
because for too long the media has
enabled the racist view of addiction and
has enabled people to,
um,
sort of say,
oh,
I'm not the typical addict.
Like,
you know,
and I used to say that and then I
realize,
wow,
that's like kind of racist,
you know,
and you know,
it comes from images that we shouldn't
have ever had.
So I think that the way to,
you know,
get beyond that.
And the way to help people with
addiction is to understand that people
with addiction are not seeking extra
pleasure.
They are not hedonist who are just out
there having so much fun using that.
You can't stop them unless you put them
in jail.
People who get addicted,
which are only 10 to 20% of the people
who use drugs like cocaine and heroin
and prescription opioids.
Those people have problems.
The drug seemed like a solution to them
until we recognize that those people are
seeking reasonably rationally to deal
with emotional and psychological
problems.
Um,
and sometimes economic problems.
We are not going to solve this problem.
And one of the things that I think we're
actually in denial about with regard to
the opioid epidemic is that while big
Pharma certainly didn't do anything good
here,
what they to say that this is caused by
purdue Pharma selling off the cotton is
to miss the fact that the people who are
overwhelmingly becoming addicted are
people who are either falling out of the
middle class or,
um,
never managed to get into it.
If you actually look at the economics of
this problem,
it's not that middle class.
People certainly don't get addicted and
it's not that rich people don't get
addicted.
It's just that if your life is despair
and you feel like it will never get any
better,
which is often the case when you lose
the American dream,
where you lose the hope for your future,
opioids are going to become very
attractive.
And the idea that we can solve this by
taking away the supply is just
ridiculous.
I mean,
as soon as we started cracking down on
the pill mills,
we started seeing a rise in heroin use.
This is not an unpredictable outcome
since we supposedly believe that
addiction is a disease.
Why would we think that simply cutting
off the supply from some patients like
turning over,
like making a thousand people,
we take this doctor out,
there's a thousand people and
withdrawal.
Now we don't provide any help for them
on why are we thinking this is going to
fix this problem and why are we thinking
that an illicit market is not going to
immediately grow up to satisfy that
demand?
Um,
the people who,
you know,
um,
the other thing that's important
economically is that in this is that
drug dealing is a way to make a living.
And if you have desperate,
unhappy people without jobs,
some of whom want to self medicate and
some of whom we just like to actually
get some money.
Um,
you are going to have a drug selling
problem and you are not going to solve
that problem by putting people in jail.
Mm.